what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so earlier today I was reading a Silver
Surfer against the tide and I really
want to cover Hickman's like Avengers
New Avengers infinity all that stuff
like right now those are the guys
remember that really old Silver Surfer
video that I did that had that amazing
monologue that was from the opening part
of against the tide like the first 20
pages or something like that it's one of
those Marvel infinite comics so it's
it's like 80 pages long but technically
in terms of like it being a complete
comic it's only like 20 so many pages
long but it's designed for digital
release and it's designed to be right on
tablet stuff like that so it makes it a
little more interesting in terms of how
it all works it's actually really cool
when you go through and start reading
them on tablet or they're really really
interesting but the fact remains here
that we will not get to Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers or anything
like that until we do the fan o stuff
and that comes after Thor which comes
after disc superior spider-man so in the
previous video I had mentioned that we
were going to stop superior spider-man
we were going to jump into spider burst
but really two videos away from
finishing superior spider-man as well
doesn't really make any sense to kind of
stop and then come back and make two
videos instead what we'll do is we'll
cover spider verse and we'll just kind
of jump back to spider burrs in the
beginning and just say all this takes
place between like everything that we
talked about from like you know X video
from like that video up until the end of
our diverse all takes place at this
point between superior spider-man and
we'll just call it a day I think that'll
be pretty it'll be a lot easier to
follow that way then it will be you know
any other way in terms of you know doing
anything kind of crazy but the fact
remains here that with this particular
video we're going to be basically
getting superior venom we're going to be
getting superior spider-man with the
Venom symbiote it actually works out
pretty well it's a really interesting
interesting concept but what Dan Slott
does here is he actually rolls over
agent venom into this Hall of Fame now
when we talked about Lee price venom
from Marvel now 2.0 we had talked about
how that was basically the evolution
really the end of the Venom symbiote
strung in terms of giving the Venom's to
be a character and giving it evolution
and kind of evolving it over the course
of marvel's publication history it's a
really made sense but what this is going
to show us is the idea that that flash
Thompson believes that he understands
the symbiote so it's kind of the early
days of growing it and evolving it and
showing us that it actually does have
sentience and where it goes and that
kind of a thing so it's pretty cool but
again this little bit of a segment with
with agent venom is pretty short it's
really just Dan Slott saying hey look
there's only a couple pages but it's
really Dan Slott saying hey look you
know agent venom is going to be facing
off against
superior spider-man so that was kind of
the cool thing because the further we
got into this the more it was like him
fighting different people so it'll be
like in this video we'll be superior
spider-man versus agent venom and then
superior venom versus the avengers so
it's kind of cool it's interesting in
terms of them fighting one another but
at this point we jump over to superior
spider-man proper and we basically join
him with the unveiling of Parker
Industries now again this is the early
days of Parker industries before it
becomes the major conglomerate that it
is right now and all-new all-different
marbles we have people like so Johny
Joffrey who have been brought on board
and a Marconi who's been brought on
board now of course Aunt May and Jay
jonah Jameson senior are basically the
silent investors they're the ones that
were kind of throwing money towards
Peter Parker and letting him be a part
of it all but at the same time we also
have like cardiac you know Elias Worth
and being part of the whole Parker
Industries team of course cardiac
basically being a guy who is more or
less a vigilante but was doing it for
the purpose of helping people physically
stealing medical equipment things like
that in order to provide healthcare for
people who just simply couldn't afford
it on their own so again it's really
cool to see these little bits and pieces
begin to come together and these little
these little blobs and bits sort of you
know create a more cohesive story from
the stuff that we've all ran over so far
even going as far back as spider-man Big
Time and of course that's really why I
was necessary because it's always just
one gigantic story and even once we
progress we get into all-new
all-different marvel when we cover
spider-verse different things like that
it'll all just continue to be one part
of a major cohesive story so again with
the idea of Anna Marconi one of the
greatest things about this is that Dan
Slott was basically using her as a way
to essentially turn superior spider-man
around and make him a good guy to give
him a reason to be a good guy now again
it's also Doc Ock so doc ock is still
somewhat nefarious and he's still
willing to commit murder but at the end
of the day it's all basically a case of
the ends justifying the means which is
not entirely wrong about I think he's a
little heavy-handed in terms of how he
deals with criminals but the fact
remains if you kill a guy for committing
a crime he won't repeat that crime
because he's dead so again it's kind of
interesting in terms of cleaning up the
streets of New York and keeping things
pretty straightforward but again this
also elliptically coincides with the
arrival of a superior spider-man facing
off against agent venom and the reason
why is because of the return of a
villain named
crime master now this is not the
original crime master and in fact this
is basically just a nobody but crime
master is an alias that has previously
been used and what we are going to find
out here
is that this is all basically being done
by a guy named Roderick Kingsley now
we'll get to him here in a little bit
but for right now the fight between
superior spider-man and agent venom is
actually pretty cool just because of the
fact that they're familiar with one
another or at least agent venom is
familiar with with spider-man in terms
of the hero and Peter Parker the problem
is that this is not Peter Parker and
again that's one of the crazy things is
because people who have known Peter for
people who have known spider-man are
used to him acting a certain way but
here he's murderous and he shows the
idea but he's going to kill agent venom
with fire you know and destroy the Venom
symbiote in the process now again this
is also Dan Slott basically building on
the whole lot agent venom concept in the
sense that Flash Thompson knows the
venom Samiha or release he understands
the Venom symbiote better than anybody
else now in terms of it actually talking
to people that's not really happening
yet instead it's more or less flash
talking to the Venom symbiote and
keeping it under control so again it's
all really just kind of growing it and
evolving it and so on and so forth but
it's also this idea that the Venom
symbiote will do whatever it needs to do
to keep itself alive it will avoid
weaknesses different things like that so
of course what a conflict is pretty
short-lived the reason for this is
because of the fact that basically agent
venom Flash Thompson bolts out and then
uses the Venom symbiote to essentially
shape-shift and keep anybody from being
able to realize who he is or what's
going on
so at this point we sort of jump over to
carly cooper now remember carly cooper
is the ex-girlfriend of peter parker and
knows that he's spider-man this is the
revelation that was basically given to
us by Dan Slott following the Spider
Island event because of the fact that
Manhattan saw all these different people
getting spider-man abilities a Peter
Parker was the only one who was familiar
with them just going through and using a
modicum of intelligence
carly cooper basically produced the fact
that Peter Parker was spider-man and so
because of this with with spider-man
acting awry with spider-man acting so
starkly different Carly Cooper's initial
idea was that's not Peter Parker
somebody did something to him and is
either mind controlling him or somehow
took over his body and so in the
background of everything that's been
going on
Carly Cooper's basically been
investigating and trying to figure out
who it is it's actually in control of
Peter Parker now where she's basically
somewhat across information that all but
guarantees the Doctor Octopus is the one
that's pulling the strings here the Doc
Ock has taken over the body of Peter she
doesn't really know how deep things go
she just simply knows the Doc Ock is
somehow in
volved in this but in the midst of her
investigations she's basically captured
by the green Goblin's people but the
fact remains that she's brought before
the Green Goblin and his question is who
is spider-man I want to know
spider-man's real identity now of course
Carly is just not willing to get that
information out it's really one of those
things where she's like I'll take it to
the grave
I'll die before I tell you it really
kind of makes sense but again a lot of
this sort of goes back and forth between
between Flash Thompson and I'm sorry
between a superior spider-man and agent
venom now keep in mind here Flash
Thompson does not have the use of his
leg the Venom symbiote is basically the
one thing that allows him to be able to
walk and so because of that the venom
soon it really has to sort of exhaust
itself you know were exhausted
disabilities more so than it normally
would if it were like Peter Parker or
somebody like that who could walk around
on his own but the fact remains here
that in the eyes of Flash Thompson
because of the fact that spider-man is
acting so completely different than what
he's used to the question is what's
going on here of course is really just
kind of looking and investigating and
see if he can't figure it out on his own
now at the same time while all this is
going on Miguel O'Hara is still around
you know spider-man 2099 is still there
and of course he's operating under the
guise of Michael O'Hara and basically
pretending to be just a member of out
him more or less speaking to jenna
jameson and so on and so forth he's just
kind of keeping an eye on things and
doing what he can to make sure that al
Kim does not become alchemax in the year
2099 but again it's just kind of Dan
Slott showing us where we where we live
and where things are sort of sitting and
how it all comes together but in the
midst of Flash Thompson basically
receiving a treatment from cardiac from
Elias or from in terms of giving him
artificial real prosthetics providing
him with artificial legs the superior
spider-man shows up for the purpose of
intend to interrogate Flash Thompson I
remember the reason why is because of
the fact that from the perspective of
superior spider-man all he sees is venom
because remember doc ock basically
purged the memories of Peter Parker so
he does not recall anything about Flash
Thompson agent venom knowing who he is
the lane he's a good guy it's just in
his mind the Venom symbiote is bad and
the Venom symbiote has to be taken out
along with whoever it is that's wielding
it and so because of that using Sonic's
superior spider-man strips Flash
Thompson of the Venom symbiote now again
this is basically kind of marketing to
the idea that flash had it under control
the flash understands the symbiote the
flash is able to bond with it in a way
that no one else can or no one else ever
has
and that's one of the reasons why a lot
of people really really love the idea of
agent venom because they look at Eddie
Brock and they say okay look the venom
Scindia and Eddie Brock go together
really really well but it was only
because of the fact that they shared a
mutual hatred for Peter Parker in terms
of a beyond the surface I genuinely
understand the Venom symbiote I you know
more or less concept that's Flash
Thompson and people loved that about
Flash Thompson giving the Venom's to be
a character getting it Drive giving it
ambition giving flash basically a larger
role in the Marvel Universe outside of
just the guy who was a dick to Peter
Parker when he was younger and the guy
who lost his legs and you know in a
wartime conflict and so because of that
the Venom symbiote basically Bond's
itself directly to spider-man now again
because of the fact that we really don't
have the Venom symbiote speaking because
it's not really talking to people all
really seems to happen here is a
venomous idiot recognizes spider-man
that says that's the guy that I
originally wanted to be with and that's
the guy that I can be with again so we
basically sort of have a superior venom
or a superior venom here and it's
actually kind of cool in terms of how he
looks because it's basically the mind of
Doctor Octopus combined with the powers
of the Venom symbiote now the funny
thing about this is that Dan flawed goes
all the way back to the post
you know 1984 Secret Wars spider-man
landscape and this entity basically says
hey look you know spider-man as we knew
him then when he became a host for the
venom simian was corrupted by he
corrupted the Venom symbiote the Samiha
corrupted him they basically became bad
guys to a degree now it wasn't a
traditional bad guy
spider-man didn't go around you know
robbing banks or anything like that but
in terms of him in relation to the hero
that we traditionally knew they were
starkly different it was night and day
and so that seems to be what's really
happening here superior spider-man is
basically running amuck with his new
abilities with with the Venom symbiote
being attached to him and it was really
kind of cool to see this unfold because
we end up seeing him taking a really
kind of cutting a swath through the
superhero community more so than he had
before because now he has a new host of
abilities at his disposal and it's
really dance-a-lot kind of showing us
we're kind of juxtaposing to the
abilities of spider-man with the
abilities of venom president turning
around and taking the entire concept and
turning it on his head when he asked the
question what happens when Doctor
Octopus is mined in the body of Peter
Parker gets the Venom symbiote then what
happens how crazy are things going to
get how is he going to use the abilities
is it possible you know is it one of
those things where Doctor Octopus can
over
the venoms Indian or will he be
corrupted with power just like everybody
else and the answer here is that he's
just like everybody else who be
corrupted by his power he'll run amok
which isn't these new abilities that he
has at his disposal now in terms of our
little section about crime master
earlier in this video and Roderick
Kingsley what we end up finding out is
that with Roderick Kingsley operating as
the original Hobgoblin and more or less
having been defeated on a multitude of
occasions
Roderick Angley basically came to the
realization that he could in a sense or
he could really just kind of grab a lot
of these d-list level villains either
villains that were small-time and died
or villains that were small-time and
walked away grabbed their villainous
identities and then use them and
essentially sell them off and that's
what he's been doing of course we know
that that Ben Urich son basically became
you know the new Hobgoblin you know feel
your kind of maintain that world for a
while before he joined the Green Goblin
we essentially have all these guys crime
master being another example it's just
small-time villains that would never
have received any attention before
getting attention here now in truth this
is a genius way to reintroduce
small-time guys it's not Dan Slott
saying hey well guys like aren't you
excited for the return of crime master
none at all we're not going to see crime
master return and play any measure of a
significant role we're going to see
something kind of interesting in terms
of the fact that we see these various
identities showing up these villains
being used by Roderick Kingsley for his
own ends and then facing off against
spider-man and different you know
different scenarios and different
situations now jumping back to superior
spider-man again because of the fact
that he's much where Peter Parker was
hosts 1984 Secret Wars he's basically
brash he's arrogant you know more so
than he was before he's prone to lash
out yeah he follows this exact same
pattern of behavior that Peter Parker
follows that was interesting about this
is Mary Jane Watson does not initially
pick up on this it's just that in her
mind she's like what's going on with you
why are you acting so violent why are
you being this way now of course once
the Venom symbiote makes his presence
known then immediately she's like oh my
god it's the same thing all over again
the venom city it's taking control of
Peter Parker now in terms of how she
deals with this it's really just kind of
like okay stay out of the way just
because Mary Jane Watson is not at a
point in any former fashion where she
could take it on not to mention this
shock of seeing the Venom symbiote again
is startling to her now of course Dan
Slott is going to use this as a way to
basically segue things back into a state
of normalcy
because of the actions of Peter Parker
because of the things that he's done
because Mary Jane Watson looks at him
that's kind of beyond the ability to you
know to return to any measure of
normalcy at least in terms of what she's
familiar with she essentially calls in
the Avengers now this is actually a
really cool situation we don't really
see like a daredevil hanging out and
just being like oh man I'm in over my
head I'm gonna call the Avengers asal
over a common pop actually made a really
had a really really good discussion
wasn't and I can't reference a comic and
he can remember it either but it was a
really cool moment I think it was
bullseye but it was an instance where
daredevil had basically taken out bull's
eye and the Avenger showed up and said
no he's coming with us and they just
took bull's eye away from daredevil but
we usually see The Avengers intervening
only in times of like a huge situation
or whenever it's convenient for this
particular scenario the Avengers are
called
by Mary Jane Watson because she's like
look the Venom symbiote return to
spider-man now in terms of what this
means for the spider-man landscape this
is Dan Slott showing us how dangerous
the Venom symbiote is which is something
that we knew about but for the modern
spider-man reader picking up after Big
Time they didn't notice they read about
it you know a time or two or maybe
they'd heard people speaking about it
they knew about it through word of mouth
but in terms of witnessing it with their
own eyes they didn't really know off the
top of their heads now this is basically
the New Avengers Iron Man Thor Captain
America Wolverine and so on these are
the New Avengers essentially coming
together for the purpose of trying to
take out the Venom symbiote but the
funny thing is that this is the Venom
symbiote with the mind of Doctor Octopus
in the body of Peter Parker and it
crushes the Avengers now the funny thing
about this is that it's not like
superior venom has inside knowledge
because Robert Doctor Octopus wiped his
mind of Peter Parker and so because of
that with Peter Parker seemingly being
purged there's nothing here to indicate
that superior venom has an upper hand on
the Avengers instead the indication here
seems to be that he's just that damned
powerful but he's just that capable he's
just that wildly durable in terms of his
strength his agility the different
abilities that he can extend you know
beyond himself in order to take out the
Avengers so he's literally it's a
one-man army
superior venom is able to hold his own
against Wolverine Captain America Black
Widow Thor and spider-woman all at the
same time and that is an incredible feat
in and of itself so it's just kind of
cool to see but in the midst of all this
Tony's sort of course be damned behind
all this basically ask the question do
we know if that slash
Thompson losing his mind or is it
legitimately spider-man now of course in
order to get an answer to this they
basically run over to Parker industries
and Tony Stark meets Flash Thompson and
this is when he realizes that is
genuinely spider-man so of course the
question now becomes what happened why
is it the flash Thompson is you know
temporarily lost the Venom symbiote what
in the world is going on here so again
this is basically Dan Slott kind of
setting the seed setting the stage for
what will become the bigger picture in
terms of superiors fireman in relation
to the Venom symbiote and the fallout of
all this when superior spider-man
finally comes to an end and so again you
know with this battle against the
Avengers wrapping up relatively fast we
basically have Flash Thompson using the
Iron Man suit to essentially show up
here of course 20 Stark lends it to him
let's go to the battlefield see if you
can't talk some sense into the venom
Scindia but the manifestation of the
venom simmias feelings and thoughts and
emotions begin to arise when flash
arrives on the scene and The Scindia
basically says look as agent venom you
use drugs to keep me subdued we don't
really work together organically you
know you basically keep me under control
chemicals and different things like that
and so because of this this is the Venom
symbiote at its most basic essentially
flashing out going crazy attacking the
various Avengers now of course in
response to this Doc Ock basically
regains himself and tries to expel the
Venom symbiote but it really isn't able
to do it on its own now again this is a
return to familiarity keep in mind Peter
wasn't able to officially and finally
cast off the Venom symbiote until he
basically encountered Reed Richards who
told him what it was Peter began to
realize what was going on with the venom
sabaean it was only when he was at his
absolute strongest that he was able to
get rid of it with regards to dr. a to
Doctor Octopus he can't do it on its own
so what is up happening here is out of
nowhere we basically end up having Peter
Parker making his return now again this
is the consciousness of Peter and what
Dan Slott basically says is that this
consciousness has basically been hidden
away from Doctor Octopus
ever since Doctor Octopus believed that
he had basically wiped it away why Peter
away from his mind so it's cool to kind
of get this returns it's cool to kind of
see this great moment show up just
because of the fact that again it's Dan
Slott saying hey look guys let's we
forget Peter Parker will make his return
so is Dan Slott kind of beginning to
wind down it's Dan Slott beginning to
sort of bring things to an end and say
okay now we're going to go ahead and
segue into the return of Peter Parker
proper and the removal of Doctor Octopus
from controlling the body of Peter we're
going to start moving into the
action of wrapping up superior
spider-man and so again because of all
this the venom Samia basically returns
back to Flash Thompson who calls it a
day and Peter Parker again more or less
comment about how Doctor Octopus still
doesn't realize that he's there and he
can more or less operate from the
shadows of his own mind so to speak and
essentially stay hidden away from
everything now again because of the fact
that this leads into goblin nation this
basically leads into the war of the
goblins what we end up getting here is a
sort of begin to wind down as things
begin to wrap up relatively fast is that
we have Roderick Kingsley more or less
coming face-to-face so to speak with the
Green Goblin and the since they're
basically communicating but again
Roderick Kingsley has basically been
building up his own army he's been
building up his own a Hobgoblin army so
to speak the various people that he's
lent his lint you know different
technologies out to but we also have the
green goblin who's been using the Goblin
formula as well as just pretty
underhanded tactics in order to create
an army form stuff and the idea here is
we're basically to have these different
goblin armies going against one another
you know facing off as this starts to
wrap up the question that's being asked
here by Tony Stark is what's going on
with Spider Man now we know previously
that when a sample was taken by the
Avengers with regards to Peter to
analyze and see whether or not there was
anything going on if he was like a
scroll or something along those lines
they basically come to the conclusion
that nobody had done anything to him but
Tony Stark basically makes the case it
says look while we were off in space we
were off doing our own thing we were
analyzing you know we were you know you
guys were working with this and that's
fine but I know this equipment better
than anybody else and when he starts to
go through it what he realizes is that
somebody had tampered with the equipment
and when the questions asked who it was
a tampered with the equipment to skew
the results of spider-man it turned out
to be spider-man himself and so again
this is basically all the roads leading
to the idea that superior spider-man is
being tracked down by the goblins and by
the Avengers basically the world is
crumbling down around him so of course
again it allows things to sort of wind
up pretty fast and since we've got maybe
one or two more videos left before
everything begins to end with regards to
superior spider-man and we start
transitioning into the return of Peter
Parker but again it's a great little
moment here so it's a great little
segment within the spider-man landscape
itself but with that being said guys if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you get the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah
I will catch you all later
[Music]
[Applause]